Okay.
Yeah,
we just got done with another crazy podcast.
I think I broke my brain
screw loose there somewhere.
I what if myself to death with Kangaroos.
That was the biggest ever.
Well I don't think so man.
I think it was 300 episodes.
I think that's up there with the biggest ones,
but I wouldn't,
I wouldn't definitively pretty amazing that you guys put out so many of these.
I mean two or three hours of intense discourse and extent.
I mean,
I'm pretty wiped out and I haven't been here.
Alpha Bray,
caffeine and marijuana,
your honor.
It's a violence.
Uh,
I'll be interested.
I'll lego you.
Uh,
do you guys have to barter,
right vitamins for the sh t shirts.
We got you those for sure.
I was sitting,
I want you to get the Andrews to ship to the guys and stuck.
So
answer me this question because nobody makes a good thing for the movie.
I forgot to ask Jeff Gaffigan to do this video.
He had to check.
You came up yesterday in Gaffney podcast,
you know,
really good one.
I actually went and looked online yesterday and it's really true that they just
need to make it a sexy,
big,
big foot like a female bigfoot in the Hendersons been they can do better.
That's crazy.
I haven't seen it.
I hadn't seen it,
but I can see,
I see,
I see as three d trailer for and from you from UDS film.
They showed it during the Singulair.
Okay.
So you got to go to singularity university and probably get him to like invite
you to one of their events and we have to pay the $12,000 12,000
will I am was there actually put your words,
they're like Sanderson culture.
They're getting more and more attention to get these ideas about optimism as
well.
Like you,
you know,
can get the word out to 600,000 mines.
Like I'm sure that there,
I don't really have a problem
coach Cremins plan to assume a thing to say there.
How many Twitter followers with national picture?
I have too many.
Yeah,
he'd breaks Twitter
gets it.
He gets shows.
Media Entrepreneur.
Is that cause it's like,
it's,
no,
it's not.
As you know,
it's profound.
It's ridiculous.
I mean,
it's amazing,
you know?
Hmm.
We'll stick with this question.
He gave up on his Twitter brother did it.
He kept on saying he kept on saying like bad stuff on it and getting himself in
trouble like that.
It's a responsibility,
right?
The microphone means you want the map before you better make sure you're saying
something.
Responsibilities.
Well,
my drunk or high tweets
where
I was telling you about was so impressed with your international following,
like people from the UK and people from like all these different people do like
the guy from Google,
like all different walks of life.
A lot of it is because of the,
you know,
it's free.
Ease of access.
When we make it as easy as possible,
we put it up in as many forms as possible,
but instead of you go into Atlanta,
right?
To give a show like every day you've transcended geography with this show
because people from all across the board,
people isn't the buckeyes daily.
Then any auditory,
right?
Like what's the best way to get across these ideas when you,
you bring such a diverse range of opinions at the table too,
so it's so good for like the fan base.
The pharmacy do.
This is where the cracks most
writing for big thing.com now it's just like this new age type of news.
Do they have a sick backdrop like first for their interview?
Right.
Awesome.
It's awesome.
We're building the,
we're starting to happen here so I'd have them right here.
These gentlemen.
I'll tell anybody here about your name.
Brian Epstein.
I pry hops and get out.
Get out of bitches.
Some of them were kicks.
Hi.
Hey everybody.
We live right now.
That's crazy.
Warrior poet.
You asked on Twitter,
also known as Aubrey.
Marcus.
The artist formally known as Chris.
We helped me almost changed your name.
Yeah.
You don't change your name again.
Boy Was it optimist.
Masters.
That was not so close.
No real before I like,
I like optimist.
I think we're going to incorporate that.
We should make it Twitter and I got into the door.
Somebody else does.
We're fine now.
Somebody else is going to try and sell that to me.
Fuck yeah,
there's benefit.
And then there's a problem with,
uh,
which was doing everything live.
I think it ups the ante though.
A lot of these guys,
they edit their shit,
you know,
they edit their podcast,
the hand,
like musical cues and all that stuff and they make it all professional and the
insert commercials in it.
But you lose something,
you lose the live element is part of what makes it fun.
You know?
I agree.
Yeah,
Even when you're listening to afterwards,
you know that it was broadcast live.
This is the,
there's a certain energy to that.
Right.
Because this one was cool.
I've lost track of time and the only thing that was keeping pace with time as I
was getting thirsty or than I should have been
top your Ios Iowasca story.
I'm like,
there's no way.
I watched,
I watched a story.
It was legendary,
but you talked it,
you're,
I became,
the story is better than you.
I want some story that's a crazy goddamn story and made me,
I don't want to do it.
I don't want to do that at all.
I was so down and do Iowasca I'm ready,
sign me up.
But I became like was just a feeling like shit afterwards.
Not into it.
I'll get all my growth through other sources.
Thanks.
It's a major,
it's a major tool.
I mean this is know you're so your close,
you need a little tack Hammer.
This is the fucking wrecking
ball.
Boom.
I think if I got hooked up heroin I'd be so down for it since I'm not on heroin.
I look at and go fuck it.
Sorry.
Ed Muskie was the guy that went crazy because hunter s Thompson accused him of
being on a Ibogaine
hunter did a lot of stuff,
but he must not have done a lot of aggregate cause just can't,
is it possible?
We did on acid,
which was interesting.
He had a very weird reaction on acid.
He would like throw a fucking shoes through windows and stuff and screaming.
People want to get his guns.
That's not good.
We had a very,
uh,
cause the way his mind works,
it worked was very strange.
You know,
it's interesting because that kind of was like there in the 60s he was there and
the hippie generation of the San Francisco Movement,
you know,
the,
the summer of love and all that,
he was there to watch like literally like that,
like what,
what everybody at the time thought was the changing of an age,
you know,
and he's got this brilliant thing in that documentary where he sort of watched
that happen and then watch the tide roll back,
you know,
and then watch like the Nixon administration afterwards and watch Vietnam after
I lost it all fall away.
And it's really fascinating stuff,
man.
He went through some shit,
man,
that generation went through some crazy shit.
He went and it was amazing.
The Hudson was legal magazines.
So many of them are still constantly,
yeah,
credible.
Well they're all wears off.
You know,
it's true.
A lot of it works and everything does that.
So that's the biggest challenge was all of this work is taking it and applying
it to your life.
After you're done,
it's very easy to get slippery and just kind of forget.
But it's always a move.
So baseline a little bit,
you know.
So where are you retreat to is never quite the same as the way you work.
Um,
the quote,
uh,
inspiration works
but it's like bathing.
Uh,
it only lasts for so long.
So we recommended daily.
Yeah.
You know,
it's really,
I don't know who,
whose quote that is,
but that's a,
that's so make sense.
Like,
yeah,
inspiration doesn't work always.
It's because you need it all at time.
You need to like it to be on that correct path.
All the checks the shamans recommend once every two months doing something to
read
a sweat lodge too.
Crazy sweat lodge.
You're ready.
I'm ready.
No,
I would gain though.
Not Interested.
No,
no.
We're going to do a little quick videos and right now I'm here with Matt Packs.
Then I'm at water cleaner at [inaudible].
At Twitter you got to go to the Adam Carolla podcast.
So like cheating on me.
Man made friends.
I did get to Primo spot.
You got to be a lot of the stories you tell them.
I don't know.
They'd be the same story stories,
motherfuckers kind of gang his stories.
Your,
your story about your,
Yeah Dude,
you were really fun and that were really inspirational.
Really good stuff.
Great stuff about the inmates and who was a,
that was a really up so we want to inform you on every APP and every episode.
Yeah.
Good job dude.
You took us on a trip today.
I'm going to have to start watching that show every week now.
I don't,
I'm scared of it though.
There's a part of me that's I caught too much shit like on my office is like not
hoarders but it's like it's good stuff.
I don't have like a,
you know any problems like missing cancer,
anything.
You'd TV to watch it and you're not aware.
You sure you can find the TV to turn on like though doesn't it?
That's what my house looks so
I need to clean your lane.
Did me not aware so much better.
It goes up.
Very Fun podcast.
Thank you very much.
If you want to check out and that's podcast.
He has his own podcast by decisions away.com and it's on iTunes.
It's also available on iTunes.
Things like if you,
I do what does it,
hey on the website
and you can follow him on Twitter.
Clever.
Cleaner,
hollow.
Sorry.
Can I get that while we're filming?
Oh,
I said it.
C Two O is so blessed.
Those guys can't do our show.
Yeah,
yeah.
They gave you so,
oh no,
they gave me a book.
Coconut water
rotate.
Perpetrate page Turner.
Yeah.
What'd you do?
Oh,
you have to do that thing where you push your finger through it and cut your
finger.
Prick and a half.
We've got to shake it and open up a little bit.
Oh,
shake it.
It's not carbonated and handed me a shake and shake a carbonated.
When you say carbonate and stuff,
oh,
you don't have to shake it.
Nothing else.
All right,
great.
That through with me.
The first end of the day,
that's what it was.
What was in the car and then here,
so then it was like a combo for a long ass stretch with no weed whatsoever.
Right.
How long did you go?
13 days.
How long has most of the launch you've ever,
I've done and I just went five or six.
But this is,
I became,
I became a heavy everyday smoker,
so to do that was really,
withdrawal symptoms were weird with the drifts onto the dreams were way,
way bigger.
But withdrawal symptoms physically like you needed zero,
zero of those.
No withdrawals don't get to it in a day.
Like if I'm like busy and I'm running around and no,
because I don't see any,
I don't just have a chance to like do something cause I'm not going to work like
quite to something important.
You know,
this doesn't count.
The only thing I've ever felt physically was,
uh,
I felt caffeine.
I felt coffee.
Oh that definitely helped that.
But like when I would take a day off and they get a headache,
that's the only,
never felt physical.
Yeah.
But with,
with pot,
it was always I,
that was,
I was tapped to be top 1% users.
Users,
there was nothing.
It was just like,
oh I didn't,
that didn't get to it.
You shut it off.
Do you believe people when they say that they have physical withdrawal symptoms
or you think that trip man,
I had aspartame withdrawal symptoms,
aspartame
to pull over and stop cause I couldn't see any more debilitating.
I didn't know that aspartame was,
it was addictive.
You ever heard of that?
I don't know if it's addictive but when I got off it,
it was in my system.
Oh but that's but isn't that also coke?
You would switch from coke.
I switched me coke to um,
to,
to sprite once and I was drinking tons of it cause it was get free of the comedy
store when I worked there.
And so because I dropped the caffeine then I got to keep driving migraines too.
But that wasn't her aspartame.
And I started doing a bunch of aspartame when you got the headaches because I
was dating this girl and she looked it up because I was having these migraines
and she said you'd be drinking a bunch of crystal light.
Cause I was at the time just shaking it up and making things,
you know,
you can
cut it out.
Migraines went away.
Didn't know what it was.
That's what she said.
It might've,
I mean that might be psychosomatic,
but there's all this stuff online so aspartame causes these things,
but sometimes not in everybody.
It didn't.
Donald Rumsfeld,
wasn't he the guy who pushed aspartame through?
I can say that where it's like not fully tested.
That's the negatives.
But then you'll get thinner.
Well when you think about it,
it matters.
Many people drink diet cokes.
It's pretty God damn safe cause everybody should be dropping like flies.
I mean it's not good for you,
but Jesus Christ,
a lot of people drinking diet coke.
Where's all the brain tumors?
You know?
I mean people like really exaggerated.
Certainly not good for your odds of you Kevin.
Sure.
Yeah.
If you live a clean life and eat healthy food,
you're definitely better off.
But you know how many people are getting cancer from diet coke?
No,
come on,
right,
Jesus.
Sorry.
Sure.
Okay.
Hey shroom fest.
July 21st the 23rd everybody,
wherever you are across the world started looking now for your connections.
I have to make sure I don't have to work that week.
Saturday,
Sunday,
Monday.
I mean that is Sunday.
Yeah,
but it might be a UFC weekend.
I'm in need of a good,
true experience though.
That's the time I think I need to go to the desert.
If you can even wait.
Loss.
That's the time.
Contact the spirit world.
Yeah.
I need a gay,
get a fucking house in the mountains,
man.
I just for that just for just for like occasional trips for relaxation.
That'd be cool if you saw that Deborah House Dab,
it'd be amazing.
That's just something like that would be the greatest thing to have ever.
You know to have like a house where you could go do this in the woods on
occasion.
You know away for Rogan.
Compound on Brian.
Everything off since Sunday.
Family to a hotel.
Pound Bro.
Starting food,
using a greenhouse.
Grow your own food.
Animals,
Blacksmith your own bullets.
Be prepared for the apocalypse son.
Have her own kettle bells.
All right.
That's it with this one.
You guys soon know everybody?
Yes,
we are here.
Joe Rogan and Brody Stevens.
Yes,
very positive today.
Brody's feeling good.
He's ready to begin his exercise.
Sure.
I am eating better.
Cutting out soda
and girls.
He's ready for Pussy.
Yes,
I am.
Back in the game.
You've got it.
It's been a year and I'm going to be back in doing what I can do.
Yes.
One whole game,
like one hill year,
brother out of the game.
Um,
do you feel any ring rust?
Yes.
Any pressure to perform?
No.
Do you have any teams you're scouting out right now?
Do you like team blonde?
I like to be below
y t blonde.
A team and team in the U hot,
passionate.
Gotta be cute.
Real hair.
Or you give a fuck real hair or you so you pushed me on the black girl.
Black girl with a wig.
What'd he say?
I that doesn't float my boat,
but I'd be willing to try it.
No,
no,
no.
I'm in there like a really white girls.
They're like a jury Nazi style.
Yeah.
Is that weird nose?
I have a Nazi fantasy.
Yes.
Gimme a chicken.
Glorious Bastard.
All Scalp.
You.
You got it.
That's what I want.
How dare you keep me down.
I'm a good guy.
Stop telling me to get laser hair removal.
I whoa.
Do it except me.
Yes.
No.
I,
uh,
I think that was about as good as we could have ever done it.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
Thanks for being on the show buddy.
Thank you.
Did y'all see a pal?
Thanks all of a grip to tell.
He throws a mean fastball and if you want to see Brody throw a fast ball in a
tennis court,
go see that on youtube.
It's on youtube.
How fast are you throwing?
That's probably now one.
Only in the mid eighties maybe,
but it's pretty fast.
It was at night.
It was on a tennis court.
Ultimate sound.
What's the fastest you've ever thrown a baseball?
I got clocked at 91 college,
Arizona State.
I can pitch with passion and I was a good pitcher.
I just like,
that's like pro speed,
right,
isn't it?
Yeah,
it's close.
Yeah.
What's like a top of the line?
What's the fastest the guy can like what?
Like Roger Clemens in his prime was probably fill him mid to upper nineties.
Yeah.
Right.
But mostly I would say mid nineties for climate was got over a hundred.
Uh,
I mean,
Nolan Ryan back in the day you got John,
uh,
Verlander now going to tiger stones over a hundred consistently.
Strasse right.
With the nationals,
hundred miles an hour starting pitchers.
There's a lot of relievers you'd do it.
How hard is it to,
I mean,
that's like,
that's amazing.
I mean,
you've got a year,
they get hit it.
I mean Fuck Justin Verlander I said Jonathan,
but I mean,
how much,
how fast do you have to be?
I mean like if Babe Ruth was alive today,
would he be shitting his pants?
Would they be throwing heat right past him?
You know,
a lot of people think that,
uh,
the guy,
I think more guys go harder now.
Yeah.
Then way back when,
way back then he probably would have adjusted.
But,
um,
it's a timing thing.
Yeah.
But the guys do time at these hitters.
They figure it out.
They'll hit a hundred miles an hour.
What's the worst thing that ever happened in baseball when they started testing
for steroids?
You know,
I'd like to see because when you're not doing steroids or HGH and ends careers,
I mean who didn't like watching Barry bonds had all those home runs,
had two who didn't like watching Roger Clemens pitch it.
42 Nolan Ryan pitched show.
He's 46 he went on steroids.
But it'd be great to see guys continue to play like after 40 you can take a
supplement,
you can take out an MMA.
You're allowed to.
There's a lot of guys.
Dan Henderson's on testosterone replacement.
Oh,
the rampage just admitted he was testosterone replacement.
Yeah,
I was at the door.
What Norman today?
No,
but for what
I,
this isn't the ice house.
You got to get around the alley.
Well yeah,
it goes behind
the shoulder,
but wonderful interview.
I don't know what just happened.
Did that guy look like a natural?
No,
no,
I didn't look like Don Johnson's Dad.
Oh,
so he's got a nice spirit.
I think they should have let the guys,
when you over 40,
you're allowed to take,
if they sponsored it,
they look at it some kind of,
and did they treat it like these guys are stealing babies.
You know,
they're making it,
all they're doing is taking something and it makes them perform better and
things that make your body perform better.
It shouldn't that just be researched more.
I mean,
it seems to me that as long as these people aren't dying and not getting cancer,
this isn't some,
some crazy stuff that goes on.
They're going to reputable doctors and they're doing this release.
Clemens was,
and I don't know,
Barry bonds was involved in that bulk of thing.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You know,
I guess they say because it makes for an uneven playing field,
but as more research comes out,
everybody hopefully would know like,
you know what,
HGH,
it's not bad for you.
It's actually good for you.
I want to take it at like a vitamin almost.
Yeah.
Um,
I think there's a lot of ignorance when it comes to it,
but it's fascinating to me.
They would spend so much time in front of Congress.
They were like,
you know,
they had this trial,
the Barry bonds trial and yeah,
as far as um,
uh,
Roger Clemens too,
I think it goes down to,
it becomes a perjury trial because they caught them saying in the past under
oath they weren't under some stuff.
Right.
Cause they can't,
it's not illegal to take human growth hormone.
It's not illegal to take testosterone,
but it's illegal as to lie when they ask you are you taking things?
Yeah.
And they did that and you had Maguire up there.
You had a,
yeah.
When McGuire took that new job,
then he had to come out and sort of explain everything.
Yeah.
He didn't get in trouble though.
It's batteries dying.
Well,
so as this conversation,
it's fucking boring anyway.
Joe's talk baseball that you take whatever the fuck they want.
That's what I say.
Don't you saying ready for the game and makes it better showing good part of
that,
that fucking games when they hit that ball only after 40 though.
Not before.
Oh folks,
today black.
We'll back bitches.
Joey Diaz always.
And John,
what's happening in beautiful people.
Another fun podcast.
My friend bed,
this podcast number one 99 you've come a long way,
baby.
It's been an interesting little ride.
It's been a lot of fun,
hasn't it?
Fuck yeah.
A couple times a month you come up here,
you talk shit.
People like it and it's free.
You get fucking entertain at work,
whatever.
I can honestly say it's transformed.
My life transformed my life as a comedian for sure.
Helped me a lot of fucking ways.
You mother fuckers are bad motherfuckers just for sticking around other support.
This we love you guys.
You know I'll tell you stories,
whatever the fuck you want to hear,
the support we get from you guys.
It's not like anything I've ever done any,
any blown the time before and it makes me work harder.
Yeah,
we work hard.
It'd be better for you guys.
So that is absolutely true from Hq.
Perform more.
I'm doing a lot of sense,
especially
gearing up for the Atlanta thing.
I'm,
we're all in like a real perfect time right now.
I been working out too soon.
Don't beautiful lawn out loud.
Wait
two hours.
What are you doing today brother?
You have to go to the spot.
No,
I got a bogie state.
Black motherfuckers have a great week.
D is in the house.
Ladies and gentleman.
Csu on one 99 podcasts.
Number one,
nine nine.
It's gone right now.
Dot.
Merera how you doing buddy?
Oh,
you're in this right,
Joe.
Hey,
stop meeting and you're talking to the world.
We just did a podcast together.
This is our video blog.
This is a nice relaxing after being with God.
We were funny.
Boy.
You know I'm not well when you're on your own,
that's about it.
You,
you have a gift to me.
A gift to you should you know that you share with other people can you can mock
if you want Joe,
but I mean it.
Sarcasm is comedy.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Do you write your own stuff?
Are you having an agile team?
Writers?
So I try to just find it written right.
Ready?
What does that Guy Brian do all the guy works on me.
How's that camera is right there?
What is,
what's wrong with him?
What's wrong with him.
He creates this,
he creates what's wrong with them.
And that is a,
it's a talent in and of itself.
It's a,
it's a part of a performance art form.
He makes me feel good about myself cause he's so much younger than me and yet
he's more pear shaped the way his hip,
lazy like a woman,
to be honest.
I curves dot.
Did you want to do,
I gave voice will list who he did.
Yeah.
There certain things.
How do you do what you can't even do with gay voice in 2012 anymore?
It's like if you're in your act and you do a gay voice,
it's like,
well it's kind of,
it's so hacky.
When you do a gay guy,
you gotta,
you gotta do them aggressive.
I think gay ski bastard.
A Tahitian.
Alright.
A gate to Haitian flight attendant and Nina,
how gay guys can get away with it more than straight guys.
Like I'm a strict guy.
He said something to you,
go fuck you.
Right.
But this guy says,
I forgot how much weight they've gained and it goes like this.
Wow,
this might be good for the stage.
He goes,
uh,
they said they're going to give you pajamas cause the flight Solon was from
Paris to La.
He goes,
uh,
what size pajamas do you wear?
I can't.
There was voice.
And he'd go,
I don't know medium.
And he hands me an extra large.
It goes Pele's.
I know,
but,
but I'm frustrating.
I did that and he went,
what are you kidding?
You go fuck you man.
But it was a gay guy.
You know,
it's funny,
but gay guys are allowed to like shit out of their cars.
They're also allows action.
Right?
Like a guy can't do that to a girl if he's not in having with her,
I give a girl came over and tried to hit on a guy and a guy won police.
Yeah,
that would be an ass.
But he can do it to a guy that's hitting,
but they can also grab a woman's breast and go,
these are so cute.
They get away with that and nonthreatening.
Yeah.
They can hug them and pal around with him down.
Every now and then they'll get drunk and do croc and they will fuck.
Really?
How do you know I don't leave them alone again guys?
Somebody told you.
Oh Trust.
The moment he stops talking to you.
Don't always buy it everybody.
Bye everybody.
Thank you don.
My Railroad,
I r.
R
powerful.
Amy Schumer,
you on video right now.
You're not even prepared me.
I need you guys to see this post food poisoning.
Not Prepared and have her parents all pumped up full of céline.
And what B drugs would they look?
They look you up with some good more fizzle.
They gave you morphine.
Wow.
What?
How they give it to you do the IB.
They don't tell you before like what's going to happen.
So I all of a sudden I'm like,
I can't feel my neck.
And they were like,
that's the morphine and like can I get a heads up if I'm going to stop feeling
body parts and went in through your arm and it kills the feeling in your neck.
Well just like numbness but yet my good though,
I heard it feels awesome.
Pretty good.
Brian,
have you ever had morphine?
No.
You gotta have you gotta get more?
Yeah,
I know they gave it to me in like a drip when I was young.
I had my first knee surgery.
Um,
and they also put you on like a perpetual motion machine that you know,
morphine drip.
Oo.
Yeah.
What's a perpetual motion?
You have one,
you have certain types of knee surgery and certain doctors,
there's a bunch of different schools of thought,
but some doctors on certain particular knee surgeries,
like a ACL reconstructions right after they do it,
they want blood flow to the knee.
Yeah.
They put you on a machine that's moving your,
moving your leg in a very limited motion.
It's not going to go any further.
A second extend anymore.
Yeah.
So it does this,
just to kind of keep your thing from freezing up is that it becomes a real
problem.
Um,
yeah.
So that's what I've got.
I don't remember it much.
I just of fuck.
Yeah.
Do you remember coding whenever,
when Nyquil had coding?
No,
I knew it dude.
He used to drink a purple.
I knew a dude.
He used to drink nyquil.
He was addicted.
He used to go out and he would go to a comedy club,
but he would have like a guidance comics.
I've run out and buy him nightfall.
Wow.
That was like his lobbying with Texas to really sad.
Yeah.
Cough Syrup.
Right.
So Cody Cody,
awesome.
Is that what they mean when they say sipping on scissors or,
oh,
it's great.
It's great.
Who's,
is there a wider human sipping on the scissor?
You said your countries,
uh,
stuff.
Yeah,
that's Sunny D.
Oh no,
it's different.
So you were ignorant to the world of the scissor until right now I did not know.
I have lived such a sheltered life.
Have you ever done that?
Brian just got fucked up on cough syrup and I know people that have,
well,
I tried that.
I remember one time I was sick and I got ahold of some of the last real nyquil.
They have the coding and I was fucked up.
I'm not so good.
A second.
I was watching TV and it was one of those old TVs and was actually going to,
you know,
remember those,
they were square for some reason and the movies were all cut off and they had
like a rounded sort of surrounding action is in the middle watching TV.
Just so happy.
Wonderful feeling.
I can see how people get addicted to that.
Yeah.
I remember thinking as I was like,
wow,
this is really nice now that could happen and then I understand that dude,
that dude that I had known about that and how to the comic that had an issue.
I'm like,
oh,
okay,
now I get it.
Yeah,
he likes a great time.
Up until I got a little while and used to be able to just blank coding and it's
essentially you're going,
you're buying like a hardcore drunk,
you drink a bottle.
Damn,
you're going to get fucked up.
I mean,
how many doses or in a bottle
bottles every weekend.
Yeah.
My mom like must have taught you well because like she always uses a spoon for
any kind of cough syrup like were like other people I've met.
They just chuck out a bottle or you know,
stuff like that.
I have been trained you students and I think that's why I never,
well well your mother's doing what?
Normal fucking humans.
I was like amazing.
She didn't just like pour it down.
My throat might say my mom used to hold me up like one of those birds.
They get fogged why out of when they force feed them and that's what she would
do.
She would shove a funnel in my mouth for the medicine.
Make Fun wa you know fog wise.
Yeah.
They serve a nextdoor to install Lucho
it's crazy.
They take this fucking dog and I opened his mouth,
shut its mouth into this too.
And then all this green comes for the force,
feed them feet,
fills him up with,
with grain and then they pull them off the thing and get them away and then they
take the next stuck and stuff is open his mouth.
Yes.
And it's now becoming legal in California until uh,
we felt rather starting in June,
starting in June,
you could still get an in Vegas [inaudible] Vegas.
But the thing is it doesn't really,
it only takes a few seconds and the ducks day and it doesn't even bother them.
It's not like a,
it doesn't affect them like the way it would affect a person,
apparently their docs and then go fuck themselves and not really sad.
I don't think Jack's really like you.
I don't think I've seen no evidence.
They want your bread when you're at the pond.
Fucking ducks,
ducks dirty bitch.
I'm gonna eat your liver.
Yeah,
we're no,
we're no better than Hannibal Lecter,
right?
So have you ever thought about going Vegan?
No.
Good for you.
I see that.
Don't say that out.
We're on the Internet.
We're here with Neil Brennan.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Video now some a sentence and paperwork for Joe.
Yeah,
we make them sign waivers because this mother fucker talks a lot of shit and I
don't want to be held responsible for any as nonsense.
You're fat
a day.
He hits right where you live,
man.
He goes to the heart.
Let's go.
Brennan has his own podcast.
It's called Champs.
The champs.
It's good.
We only have mostly blacks.
We've had a Blake Griffin.
We've had Queslo,
we've had a sega,
but he also,
he also had,
uh,
what's the porn stars name?
Sasha grey.
Flash of gray.
Where the guy,
cause she's got to get white boyfriend.
His name is flying Lotus.
Another dude.
He's fun.
Awesome.
Flying Lotus.
Yeah.
But yeah,
that's not,
no,
that's not her boyfriend.
That's it.
That is a black guy.
That was also on the show.
Yeah.
Flying Lotus made that one of the most incredible videos ever.
Right?
Isn't he the one that did that?
Tim and Eric Video.
Yeah.
You see the music behind the Tim and Eric Video?
The one with the guy who goes to the disco.
No,
I don't think that he did that.
So I don't know.
That might be major lazer.
Yeah,
it's major Lazer boot.
Is it major Lazer in?
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
I am a fucking,
I am a useful piece of disinformation.
That's why I'm leading cable,
right answer.
Yes.
Eventually your stupidity leads us down the right path.
I could fuck up your Google search so you can be convinced them right off and
I'm wrong.
Well,
that's it,
folks.
We just wanted to say hi here.
It's Neil Brennan and make sure that if you enjoy Neil on our podcast,
you subscribed to him.
You'll like the champs,
the champs,
especially if you're really into talking to black guys.
Yeah.
All right.
Later,
the Joe Rogan experience
[inaudible]
and half,
and the other one's like now.
Oh,
so you DJ.
Why you chose,
okay,
it's about to rain.
Okay.